Comencemos por aclarar algo el fin de la
emergencia no supone el fin de la
pandemia y la OMS pida los países no
bajar la guardia Qué es lo que no deben
hacer por tanto los estados a nivel de
salud pública y Cómo mantener la
vigilancia y al tiempo el retorno a la
normalidad Buenas noches Rodrigo mucho
gusto En realidad se termina el periodo
agudo de la pandemia que permite la toma
de decisiones por una cuestión de
emergencia facilitar recursos
movilización de los mismos sin embargo
el mismo anuncio nos dice hay que estar
Muy cuidadosos de lo que puede venir
sobre todo con un virus que tiene muchas
mutuaciones y sigue habiendo mutaciones
Y eso es muy riesgoso pudiéramos tener
un repunte en cualquier momento tenemos
que cuidar que no vaya a haber este tipo
de situaciones tenemos que vigilar
aquellos pacientes que tienen covid
prolongado Porque esa es una de las
situaciones que no sabemos cómo va a
impactar a los servicios y sistemas de
salud por demanda de situaciones que no
estaban previstas o que no conocemos que
tenemos que investigar de una mejor
manera los estados deben seguir
preparándose para un eventual epidemia
un eventual pandemia que sabemos que
puede venir no sabemos cuándo pero sí
puede llegar entonces este tipo de
situaciones Nos invita a estar atentos a
seguir con las medidas sobre todo las
personas mayores de 65 años debemos de
seguir cuidándonos sugiero utilizar el
cubrebocas
grabado de manos obviamente pero el
cubrebocas es una de las medidas más
efectivas no olvidemos que de las
vacunas que tenemos la vacuna contra la
influenza la debemos de tener Y si hay
una campaña de poner refuerzos hay que
vacunarse para evitar una reinfección o
una infección por covid y quería venir
ahora a la región latinoamericana y
quería preguntarle si sale esta región
mejor parada de la crisis por el covid
19 O al contrario
abierto una brecha mayor con respecto a
las regiones más ricas yo creo que todas
las regiones del cono Sur fuera de lo
que es Europa Estados Unidos Canadá nos
pegó de una manera más fuerte primero
por el acceso a las vacunas la poca
disponibilidad que hubo la variedad de
vacunas que hubo de disponibilidad la
disponibilidad tardía de las mismas pero
también tenemos que considerar que
económicamente nos nos afectó de una
manera muy fuerte y nos demostró también
que nuestro sistema de salud tienen
estaban en un estado de fragilidad muy
importante yo creo que esto también
invita a los gobiernos a reflexionar qué
pueden hacer para ir fortaleciendo los
servicios y sistemas de salud para ir
ampliando la cobertura y el acceso a los
a los servicios de salud porque no es
nada más tener más centros de salud sino
que la gente los pueda llegar y los
pueda utilizar y poderlos ir preparando
creo que estos son los mensajes que los
gobiernos deben de tener aquí hay que
invertir en infraestructura hay que
invertir en personal médico hay que
invertir en la preparación para evitar
lo que ya vivimos con el covid ante una
eventual nueva pandemia Rodrigo